we're having a think today about how to
put together
the results we've been looking at over
the last week and a half
we've been looking at simple harmony
motion bless you and we've also been
thinking about
mechanics and motion in more general
terms i want you to think back
very first lesson right when we're
thinking about simple harmonic motion
and the forces
acting upon an object that is
oscillating back and forth right
what can you tell me if we had a very
simple differential equation
that explained to us that articulated
what the forces were what the
acceleration was acting on an
object moving in simple human motion in
terms of its displacement what was that
yeah go ahead
fantastic minus n squared x if we're
moving about
x equals zero and we could just like
push on that just a little bit if we
want to move somewhere
around somewhere else instead of x
equals zero instead of
just x we would say x minus c
or plus it doesn't really matter right
but this just puts things in a positive
frame for us okay
so this is good right we've got this
frame but it only works for simple
harmonic motion or specifically it's
it's actually the way we know
if you have some kind of object and you
know you can satisfy this equation
that's what tells you it's like an
indicate oh it's simple harmonic motion
then we went and sort of took one step
aside and we said you know what
regardless of whether something is
simple harmonic or not whether it's
oscillating or not
we can actually state the forces acting
on it again
in terms of displacement we had to use
the chain rule we actually had to use
the chain rule
a couple of times we could state
the forces the acceleration acting on
something
in terms of a derivative that was
with respect to x can someone help me
remember what was the weirder looking
thing
that fit up here half a square thank you
taran right
strange i remember very distinctly
learning this when i was in year 12 and
being
drastically confused by it but the whole
idea is very simple
i just want to think about forces
acceleration
in terms of displacement and a couple of
applications of chain rule and you look
back at that derivation we did
a few days back we'll get you to this
now clearly you can see the way i was
leaning was to say
well here's one way of looking for us in
a particular situation here's another
what happens when we put them together
so
on your next line underneath this right
we can say combining these results what
are we going to be able to get
[Applause]
what will this help us to see well if i
just
make a substitution here right and say
i've got this derivative
of half v squared and we know it's
v's but i'm picturing v as some function
of x that's why i can differentiate it
with respect to x
in simple harmonic motion it's going to
be this
right so i'm going to write my minus n
squared x minus
c like so now what i want to try and do
here
is push on this relationship and see
what i can learn from it
right now because you've got a
derivative with respect to x on the left
hand side
and a function also in terms of x on the
right hand side
what i can do is go from this to an
integral every statement about a
derivative
is like a backward statement about
integration right
what i could do here is i could
integrate both sides with respect to
what's the variable it's all x's right
so i'm going to do that right just
before i do that i'm going to do one
step that
may look a little strange but it will
make things easier for me in a second
see this half that's in the half v
squared remember it came from
integration that's where it's sort of um
it's the integral of v because it's just
a constant coefficient i'm going to
pull it out i'm going to take this half
out it can just sort of write it out
here
if i want and in putting it out there
the reason it's there is so i can
multiply through by two
and get rid of that fraction you'll see
in a second why this is going to be
useful thing
what do i got here if i multiply through
by that
two right it's just a constant
coefficient so whether it's inside or
outside the derivative no big deal
it's going to be a multiplication by 2
on the right hand side
but i'm going to write it in a bit of a
weird spot follow along with me
i've got this minus n squared out the
front it's just a constant of some kind
depending on what n is and the two that
i've multiplied on both sides
i'm going to put it here
you might say mr that's a weird spot to
put it i know it is weird
it's partly because i know where i'm
going on the next step and you don't
potentially
yet though i gave you some clues morning
welcome
i said this statement about derivatives
is like a statement about integration in
disguise
so on this next line i'm about to
integrate i'm about to integrate
let's do the left hand side because it's
easy when you integrate something like
this which is a derivative
what do you get back just b squared
right
when you integrate the derivative you
return back to your original function
great
over here on the right hand side this is
tricky it's kind of a theme throughout
the course but particularly this topic
mechanics
you kind of have some algebra soup over
here you need to see through
okay minus n squared
negative n squared just a constant right
so for the purposes of integration i'm
just going to kind of
leave it there okay have a look at this
i could expand i could
but do i need to like think about this
i'm integrating up right
this is at the moment a linear function
so when you integrate up
in terms of x because c is just a
constant when you integrate up you're
going to get a
quadratic right so this is really just
like integrating 2x
you increase the power from a 1
to a 2 and so you then divide by that
new power which is
two that's actually why i put the two
there okay so just watch closely
you get your constant hanging around
there constant coefficient i should say
and then this integrates up into x minus
c
all squared see why i did that it's a
bit of a weird step to to do this
directly but hopefully you can see why i
put that two there i'm almost done
i integrated did i have boundaries
no so this is an indefinite integral
which means there's a
constant integration flying around
somewhere really there's a constant
integration from both of these integrals
but
constant integration another constant
equation put together
it's just some other constant okay i
normally call my constant c
that's a bad idea in this context
because c is
the center i just need some other letter
i'm going to call it k
because that's another letter i commonly
use for constants and just over here
to make sure i know what i'm talking
about i'm just going to specify the k's
some number
okay now i'm going to pause here for a
moment okay we've made some progress
right what we have done is we've gone
from understanding
the forces the acceleration in terms of
displacement
and now we've got something to do with
the velocity
in terms of displacement that's progress
but then i've got this
i've introduced this problem because i
integrated no boundaries of course i've
got this
now how are we going to evaluate this
constant we can
right the way we're going to evaluate
this is by thinking about
what you know about the velocity of a
particle
that's moving under simple harmonic
motion
if you have i need another color if you
have an object
that's moving under simple harmonic
motion and as soon as i wrote this you
knew it was simple harmonic motion right
what do you know about the particle's
velocity that will help you
to find out this constant right i need
to do some stuff that's going to
cancel things out right what do i know
like if you picture i
think i left my um no i've got a spare
right here we go
if you picture back to that illustration
i gave you the road band right so you
got this oscillating object and
you know it goes back and forth and back
and forth at what point in this
object's motion in my fingers motion do
you know useful things about the
velocity
of this object what can you tell me any
takers
brian what are you thinking
at the maximum point now i think i know
what you mean
in terms of maximum but you're like when
i'm furthest away from the center of
motion we have another sort of fancy
word for that starts with an e that
we've used before
the extremities right at the extremes of
motion okay
uh we knew what you meant right okay at
the extremes of motion
you stop because otherwise it wouldn't
be the extreme of motion you stop there
and then you come back
and so on right so in other words at
some particular point that i can define
i know that under simple and you should
write this down by the way
under simple harmonic motion we know
when the velocity
is zero it's at these extremes okay
now where are those extremes in this
sort of scheme right
well you're going to go from
some chosen center and it's some
distance
in one direction and then the same
distance in the other direction do you
agree
what do we call that distance by the way
starts with an a
that's the amplitude because we're
thinking trigonometric functions right
so
that amplitude is how far left and right
we go
right so the velocity is zero when the x
value
is you've got to measure from the center
so i'm going to put a c
there for center and you can go in
either direction
by that amplitude so i guess i could say
plus or minus a
is that okay this is where the velocity
equals
zero if c is our center of motion if
a is our amplitude can i pause for a
moment
and see what you can do with that what
i'm trying to do is use that information
i use those conditions if you like to
try and find out what v
or rather what k is equal to that's the
constant integration i'm after
can i pause for about 30 45 seconds see
what you can come with we're looking for
a value
of k see what you get i'm going to show
you what's going to go on here but i
have a question for you so have a think
about this
okay here's me substituting in one of
these values one of these extremes of
motion i've chosen c
plus a but in a second i'm going to ask
you
why it doesn't matter whether i choose c
plus a or c
minus a you might think putting in
totally different values
for v equals 0 might make something
different but in this case as you'll see
in a second it won't
here's me substituting it in right so
you can see what's nice about this
though of course we would expect it
because things should cancel out
wherever your center of motion is it
will cancel right if your center of
motion was x equals 2 you're going to
get a 2 plus your amplitude minus 2.
so those things are going to cancel out
that's not there
and my k is the thing that i'm after so
really all i need to do is add this
entire
term here whatever it ends up being to
both sides and you get your value of k
which is by the way
n squared a squared which
in a second we're going to put back into
our expression for v squared and then we
can tidy this up this thing up
here's my question to you right i chose
c plus a because i'm
discriminatory towards negative signs
because they hurt my brain but i could
have just as easily chosen c minus a
why's that because i square it right you
see i'm squaring here so even if this
was c
minus a it'll be negative a squared
we should have expected that from the
beginning because this is a symmetrical
situation
isn't it right the whole point is
whichever side you're on you're acting
in the opposite direction so that's why
you get this
symmetrical situation that's just what
the algebra looks like but visually
you can see it harks back to this
situation one extreme
other extreme same thing is happening
what's our expression now for v squared
i'm going to substitute in
this value of k and then we can tidy up
just a little bit
i've got this minus n squared x minus c
squared that i got from integration
and now here comes n squared a squared
okay
any suggestions for how i can do a teeny
bit of tiny up here
i'll factorize n squared and while i'm
at it
i'm also going to place this in a more
sensible order for me
i'm going to place the i should have
drawn a square bracket there i'm going
to place the
positive term the a squared out the
front
and then i've got this x minus c all
squared
on the other side are you happy with
that does that look okay
all right question for you i want to go
back to your uh one of the problems that
we had a look at earlier in the week
on the right hand on the left hand side
you've got v squared there
v squared has to be positive because
we're in real number land at the moment
right
what complex velocity looks like anyway
i'm not going to think about that too
much
i've got this v squared over on the left
which has to be positive
over here i've got n squared also has to
be positive
and then i've got this thing there's a
subtraction here
i'm like slightly concerned can this
ever be negative this thing here in the
brackets
just on the basis of the algebra it
looks like it's totally possible
right something take away something can
be negative
sometimes but i want you to think this
is not just some random situation
this is simple harmonic motion so i want
you to think all the way back
to nature of proof to some of the
inequalities that we used and worked
with there can anyone talk me through
how can we know actually this thing's
never
going to be negative doesn't always have
to be positive but
will definitely be non-negative which i
know is a distinction that caught us in
one of our recent assessments
not necessarily positive but definitely
non-negative can anyone
give me any suggestions or clues yeah
okay all right so if you can't if you're
not quite following here right we're
gonna amplitude here squared
and this thing here can't just be
anything you like the
x has these kinds of boundaries right
that's the
domain of x so if you have a think about
this
i'm not going to use that color because
it wasn't very good if you haven't think
about this
write this underneath with me right x
can't just be anything
it has to be locked in between c minus a
and c plus a yes
so therefore relating this to the
amplitude if i subtract c from
everything in this inequality what do i
get
i get negative a x minus c
and then just a see what i did there
subtracted c from everything it's just a
constant i can do that
how do i get from here to here to
understand what's going on
i have this squared do you agree with
that when i square though
again think back to your knowledge of
inequalities you got to be really
careful here because there's all these
negatives going on right
once i square i am going to get an a
squared what can you tell me about the
direction of the inequality
this thing's smaller than this so when
you square it
its square should be smaller than the
other square right
same deal over here but this negative
just ends up being another version of
this because negative a times negative a
still a squared following so far so now
how do i get over to this well looks
like i'm going to subtract this from
both sides
that leaves me with a 0 on the left and
an a squared minus
x minus c all squared on the right
zero is less than a thing means that the
thing is greater than or equal to
zero that's saying that this is
non-negative do you see
how i've reasoned that so this thing
here
is greater than or equal to zero of
course it can be equal to zero
because sometimes you're at the extremes
of motion you stop moving so far so good